when did it dawn on you that it was okay
to be married because you had said i'm
probably never going to be married is
ashton that well firstly he's very hot
right he's very attractive right and so
why not lock in and marry him i mean
who's better than him right no i don't i
don't even know what to tell you like i
think it took my parents by surprise i
think it took everybody by surprise when
i was like yeah i want to do this i
think it took him and i both by surprise
we started dating with the idea we both
were never going to get married because
especially he just got out of his mouth
so he just got out of a marriage i got
out of a long relationship i was single
and having the best time ever and dating
totally dating having a great time and i
was like i'm never getting married he's
like great neither of mine we're like
shaking hands on it we're like life is
great yeah
a year later we're like tomorrow let's
get like it just were you shocked that
the guy that you kissed that could give
you your first on-screen kiss yes like
all of a sudden now you were becoming
romantically involved you never expected
that yes because you thought of him as a
friend
yeah
yeah when we first ran into each other
we always kept in touch on um like a i
am remember that at like aol yeah yeah
yeah yeah aim game yeah so we always
kept in touch like since after 70s like
we would pop on each other's like hey oh
my god how are you how's life like
everything's good great and you still
were not thinking of him romance no no
no i mean like not at all and then we
ran into each other um out and about at
a party yes and i tell you this party
was it it was at an award show so i see
this guy and i see his back and he's
really tall and i was like who's that
tall guy i'm 5'4 and he's 6'4 i mean
he's literally you know i love romance
he it's so he i was like who's that tall
guy and i'm standing there like this
literally like hmm
and i'm wearing this big poofy dress and
you look ridiculous
doing that big poofy dress shut up
howard and then and then he just turns
around and it was literally like if we
were in a movie like the music would
start playing and violence would go i
literally went
like i think that he for the first time
ever took my breath away like i just
that's the best way i mean suddenly
after all the years of working together
on the same show he turned around and
you were like wait a second i was like
[ __ ] he's good looking
like i don't know what i don't know if i
just all of a sudden could see well and
like saw 2020. i don't know but i was
like but maybe it's because you were
more worldly now you had been through
dating and stuff and all of a sudden you
said you know what what am i a schmuck
for why not be into this guy yes i think
we both had to go through a lot in our
lives to become the people that we were
because we would never be together based
on the people that we used to be i had a
similar experience with him i met him
and he turned around music the music
started
he didn't give me the time of day but
he's a great guy